Professor Michael Clarke who's joining
me again in the studio Michael just
outline for our viewers The Contours of
the relationship between Russia and
China over the last 12 months and indeed
how significant is this 12-point plan
from China yes I mean China won't
condemn Russia outrights have been three
big votes in the United Nations in the
general assembly the last one was this
week and they've China's always lined up
with the the neutrals they've abstained
so they won't condemn Russia but they
are being careful not to offer too much
help they haven't offered any Military
Support so far not outright military
support and they've sort of restrained
the Russians from talking too much about
nuclear weapons and boasting about
nuclear issues and so there's a there's
a close relationship between Russia and
China but it's not it's not absolutely
unconditional at all and this 12-point
peace plan is unacceptable to Ukraine
and to the West because it says there
should be a ceasefire immediately well
that means that the Russians keep all of
the game things they've just made they
keep all the all the conquests and but
there are at least five points out of
this 12-point plan that the west and the
ukrainians would agree with on prisoner
swaps on humanitarian Aid on making
nuclear uh uh um
nuclear bases safe the nuclear civil
nuclear power station safe within
um Ukraine and not making nuclear
threats so there's quite a lot in this
peace plan which the West will go along
with but the essence of the plan is
unacceptable because it basically means
that the Russians would win okay all
right but a bit more Nuance in it than
on first inspection uh another
development is that the Belarusian
president lukashenko is going to China
on a three-day visit what realistically
could he achieve there yeah I mean not
so much really and in a way this is the
the Chinese I think indicating that
they're not only dealing with Russia
they're dealing with another country
that's involved in the conflict I mean
Belarus has is not important to to to
China in any real way they've got some
Investments there it's not so many but
really this is China indicating that
they're thinking in Regional terms not
just in terms of their relationship with
Putin so I think it it diffuses
criticism in a way that they're favoring
Putin too much and you know diplomatic
visitors and diplomatic visits but of
all the people who might go to represent
Putin lukashankar is the is the is the
puppet the Putin completely dominates
yeah yeah that's been interesting to
observe hasn't it all the way through
um let's talk about what's happening on
the ground the main battle areas in the
east of Ukraine
um the Wagner mercenary group is pretty
strong there what is the latest yes I
mean they're making progress of back
they look as if they're cutting it off
they've taken control of the main route
into back but the mo3 the main Highway
and there's another one called the h-32
which is a a smaller Road and it's the
only way out that the ukrainians have
now got and that road is now being
fought over North and South if if they
have to withdraw they'll have to
withdraw down this minor road to the
Southwest the age 32 and I suspect that
they may have to before too long we know
quite a lot now about Wagner
tactics this mercenary group tactic
using criminals in the front line people
say they commit human wave attacks it's
not quite that what they work in
eight-man groups eight-man units and
they sit they send the first eight-man
unit that they call the the Storm
Troopers they give them the best
equipment and they send them across a
piece of ground that they're trying to
take and their job is to go until they
get fired on to go until they meet
contact and then they hit the ground and
start digging furiously and while
they're on the ground then Wagner's
artillery comes in and hits ahead of
them and when they've done a little bit
they send the second group in to jump
into the trenches that the first group
have created and then a third group of
eight and then a fourth group of eight
and they move forward leapfrogging each
other digging trenches for the next
group to go into now Wagner say
traditionally they say well four groups
will take it you know Stormtroopers and
three group so they call them musicians
who jump into the train I don't know why
but they call them musicians they jump
into the trenches in reality the reports
are they've taken 10 12 15 groups to
capture 50 or 60 yards of territory so
they've been they've been employing 120
140 men sometimes and they've been
losing 70 or 80 basically absolutely
yeah and they've been using they've been
losing up to 80 percent of their troops
in taking 100 meters of ground so it's
it's and the Russian army can't do this
because they won't
um you know soldiers are more sensible
in the Russian army and they don't get
shot if they turn back the thing about
the Wagner people and the criminals that
they've been using the convicts that
they've used is that they say they say
if you give up if you turn back we'll
shoot you anyway so you keep going
forward and there's a lot of anecdotal
evidence from Ukrainian defenders in
back mode saying we can't believe it
these people three or four of them get
shot on the and the other two keep on
coming because that's their best choice
that is I mean the best they can hope
for is to be careful captured or wounded
umut is the latest there is that's
what's happening yeah I mean in back
much itself they've taken about a third
of the city the Eastern third of the
city they probably won't get the rest of
it but they have taken the access roads
and so I think the Wagner group will
probably succeed in Bachmann but the
cost has been enormous because of these
tactics they use of always going forward
in eight-man groups with no turning back
allowed interesting okay Michael thank
you very much